we have questions from our students
particularly related to your politics
and your social justice activism dan
okay so after in an interview after your
wedding you stated that you hope that we
translate all of our beliefs political
and personal into all of the work that
we do I'm wondering do you see that as a
personal choice or a moral obligation so
do you think that's something that binds
other filmmakers or producers for
instance well I think it when i was
speaking of it i was daring to speak
only for myself in that it was a
personal choice but i do believe it is a
moral obligation and so i would
certainly encourage other people to
believe to believe that it is as well
when you forge a career in the
entertainment industry if you're lucky
enough to be a part of a film or
television show or a Broadway theater or
some type of art that gets a wide
audience it becomes in capable to you
that what you have created does have
reach and it does go out into the world
and it's going to affect the world one
way or the other so I do believe that
you are to some extent responsible for
what that effect is going to be however
they're also I there is and there should
be at many times a line between art and
politics so for me the fact that I'm
doing both helps me separate those
things that if I'm doing a fictional
film then I'm not going I wouldn't ever
dream of censoring something in that
film if it wasn't politically you know
strictly adhering to my beliefs doing a
film like milk is a different matter
certainly but so you know your fictional
work should express a variety of
different viewpoints but then your
political work and social activism work
you know I believe in it in a perfect
world is should be very specific to you
deeply passionate to you and something
that you completely believe in